pas d'accès direct à la boutique mais un
retrait juste devant la porte principale
un système de drive improvisé afin de
permettre un maintien de l'activité
depuis le début du confinement
l'enseigne saveurs des comptoirs s'est
adapté et recentrer sur l'activité de
vente de thé et de café
j'avais un gros doute sur le fait que ce
soit ouvert mais bon après je me dis que
le café c'est quand même un produit de
première nécessité donc pourquoi pas
j'ai tenté ma chance
étant moi-même artisans sur saint
quentin en yvelines je me dois de faire
travailler d'autres confrères artisans
commerçants donc c'est pour ça aussi que
je viens dans ces petites structures là
déjà on l'a fait pour nos clients
ensuite on l'a fait parce que il faut il
faut que la boutique puisse tourner on a
déménagé cette année l'année dernière ça
fait un peu plus six mois
donc c'était un gros projet avec des
gros enjeux donc aujourd'hui il faut
qu'on assure la pérennité de notre
entreprise
le manque à gagner est d'ores et déjà
importants avec un chiffre d'affaires
divisé par deux depuis trois semaines
est ce que certain c'est que d'une part
on n'a pas perdu une partie de notre
notre clientèle toute la clientèle qui
vient notamment de de gérer 2
de d'assez loin pas forcément la
proximité même de la boutique qui ne
peut plus se déplacer aujourd'hui la
clientèle d'entreprises qui ne va plus
au bureau
malgré tout les dirigeants ont décidé de
limiter les recours aux aides mises en
place par l'état notamment les reports
de charges et une seule salariée est
aujourd'hui en chômage partiel
c'est sûr que par contre la reprise
risque d'être compliqué c'est un peu le
jir elle pleut inconnu dans cette
histoire c'est comment voilà comment le
leur tour gérait le dégonflement va la
base passé mais c'est sûr que ça aura
des impacts économiques à moyen terme
puisque 20 tout l'argent qui ne rentrent
pas aujourd'hui dans les entreprises
et puis chez les particuliers
forcément ne se retrouvera pas sur le
sur l'économie demain donc c'est sûr que
ça sera la fin d'année 2010 2020 sera
forcément plus compliqué